guerroyer jusqu'à la mort c'est le lot
quotidien de ces chevaliers de l'époque
des croisades représente le tonique
order voilà une compagnie de moine
soldat du 13ème siècle la terre sainte
c'est pas facile faut il croire il faut
avoir à coeur ardent les représenter les
siens ça lui donne du courage de la
vente et non loin de là aux portes du
château les curieux s'arrêtent pour
admirer la cour de charles vii et de la
reine marie danjou fait le plein de
trouvailles et mon prix c'est la dorsale
sont bien déguisés sont bien harnachés
c'est génial c'est une ambiance
particulière
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir habituellement donc le succès un
peu partout les voilà les skis a été
créé avec le chapiteau la vie à la vie
du moyen-âge et encore c'est sympa c'est
une belle fête
le moyen âge une époque pleine de
symboles pour notre monarque d'un jeu la
royauté
les chevaliers l'amour courtois les
belles dames des châteaux forts puis
aussi les croisades aussi la lutte entre
la france et l'angleterre dont
l'organisateur des festivités célébrer
l'époque médiévale ce n'est pas
seulement du folklore il se crée une
amitié fantastique entre les gens qui se
passionnent pour cette époque
l'amitié est si forte que du coup on est
très heureux du maine le moyen âge ses
chevaliers leurs armes
d'ailleurs certains utilises tu encore
pour pratiquer le bo ou un sport où les
spectateurs ont grand intérêt à garder
leurs distances avec les combattants